The sex talk is never an easy conversation. For boys, the questions about sexual consent, average penis size, how to ask someone on a date, and how to decide when to have sex, are often not asked and thus unanswered. As a result, boys get their information from the internet, the movies, and their friends, and end up coming to their own conclusions about what most guys think. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist about what most guys are really thinking and how that challenges masculine stereotypes. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology.
性教育从来都不是一件容易的事。对于男孩来说，关于性同意、平均阴茎尺寸、如何约会以及如何决定何时发生性行为的问题，通常无人问答。因此，男孩们从互联网、电影和朋友那里获取信息，并最终对大多数男人的想法得出自己的结论。在本期节目中，我们与一位心理学家探讨了大多数男人的真实想法以及这些想法如何挑战男子气概的刻板印象。我是奥德丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学访谈”。
Andrew Smiler is a therapist and writer living in Winston-Salem, North Carolina. A developmental psychologist, Dr. Smiler, is the author of the new book, Dating and Sex, a Guide for the 21st Century Teen Boy, which is published by the American Psychological Association. He has also authored more than 20 journal articles and book chapters relating to boys, men, sexual development, and identity issues. and is currently an associate editor of the APA Journal, Psychology of Men and Masculinity. Welcome, Dr. Smiler.
安德鲁·斯迈勒是一位居住在北卡罗来纳州温斯顿-塞勒姆的治疗师和作家。作为一名发展心理学家，斯迈勒博士是美国心理学会出版的新书《21世纪青少年男孩约会与性指南》的作者。他还撰写了20多篇关于男孩、男人、性发育和身份认同问题的期刊文章和书籍章节，目前担任美国心理学会期刊《男子与男性气质心理学》的副主编。欢迎您，斯迈勒博士。
Thank you for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. So the common assumption about teen boys is that sex is all they think about, right, all the time. But there seems to be very little discussion out there about how to talk to boys about sex, romantic relationships, and just being a boy, juggling various demands in their lives. Based on your research and your work with adolescents, do you think boys, want more information that goes beyond your typical school health class? How do they juggle all that's being thrown at them? That's a great question, and they absolutely want more information than what they're getting. And first off, we know that only about half of American teams get any kind of sexuality,
谢谢邀请我来。很高兴来到这里。因此，人们对十几岁男孩的普遍看法是，性是他们满脑子想的全部，对吧，而且无时无刻不在想。但是，关于如何与男孩谈论性、恋爱关系，以及仅仅作为一名男孩并在生活中应付各种要求，外界似乎很少进行讨论。根据你的研究和针对青少年的工作，你认为男孩们是否想要更多超出学校健康课范畴的信息？他们是如何应对铺天盖地而来的信息的？这是一个很好的问题，他们绝对想要比现在更多的信息。首先，我们知道大约只有一半的美国青少年接受过任何形式的性教育，
education in their middle schools or high schools. So there's a lot of kids that never really have that health class that talks about the biology. And we know that most of those health classes don't talk about relationships at all. At the same time, survey of whether we're talking to eighth graders or 10th graders or 12th graders, about 80 to 90% of teen boys and similar numbers of teen girls, tell us that they've been in a romantic relationship of some sort. That's a much higher percentage than the number of kids had sex at any given time or any given age. So there's a whole lot of dating on and going on and only a fair amount of sexual activity,
在他们的初中或高中阶段。因此，有许多孩子从未真正上过探讨生物学的健康课。我们知道，大多数健康课根本不谈论恋爱关系。与此同时，无论我们采访的是八年级、十年级还是十二年级的学生，大约80%到90%的青春期男孩以及相差无几比例的青春期女孩都表示，他们曾有过某种形式的恋爱关系。这个比例远高于在任何特定时间或年龄发生过性行为的孩子数量。因此，有大量的约会正在发生，而性行为则只有相当一部分，
of course more as they get older. One of the things that I find when I talk to teen boys, one of the things that comes across pretty clearly in the research, is that boys don't have a good sense of understanding about how relationships work. This makes a lot of sense if you look at kind of the media content that's geared towards teenage boys and compare it to what's geared towards teenage girls. If you're watching shows or your sons are watching shows like The Sweet Life of Zach and Cody, or if they're watching Harold and Kumar or even the Avengers movies.
当然随着年龄增长会更多。当我与青春期男孩交谈时，我发现的一件事，也是研究中非常清楚地体现出来的一点，那就是男孩对恋爱关系是如何运作的并没有一个很好的理解。如果你看看针对十几岁男孩的媒体内容，并把它与针对十几岁女孩的内容进行比较，这就非常合乎情理了。如果你在看节目，或者你的儿子们在看诸如《小查和寇弟的顶级生活》这样的节目，或者如果他们在看《猪头逛大街》甚至《复仇者联盟》系列电影。
The point in there where the guys actually talk about how do relationships work. Certainly in the Avenger movies and Iron Man, we see Tony Stark having all of these problems with women that he slept with. And we get moments of his relationship with Pepper. A little kind of detailed discussion about relationship dynamics, about how does this relationship work? do I trust you? Why do I trust you? Anything like that. If you look at shows that typically have female audiences, whether we're talking 90210 or Gilmore girls or pretty little liars, that's a
其中的重点在于，男人们实际上是在讨论恋爱关系是如何运作的。当然，在《复仇者联盟》和《钢铁侠》中，我们看到托尼·斯塔克与他睡过的所有女性都有这些问题。我们捕捉到了他与佩珀关系的片刻。关于关系动态、这段关系是如何运作的、我是否信任你、为什么信任你等细节讨论却很少。如果你看那些通常拥有女性观众的节目，无论是《飞越比弗利》、《吉尔莫女孩》还是《美少女的谎言》，那都是
substantial part of the conversation. Do I trust this person? Do I want to be physical with this person? How physical do I want to be with this person? I used to not like this person now they're trying to be my friend. How much should I trust them? Should I believe them? So boys are really kind of lacking a whole piece of education around how really girls get. And boys want that knowledge because they are having relationships and they want to know how they work. Your latest book, again, Dating and Sex, A Guide for the 21st Century Teen Boy, is written for boys who are coming to terms with, like you say, the complex sexual world around them.
对话的大部分内容。我信任这个人吗？我想跟这个人有身体接触吗？我想跟这个人有怎样程度的身体接触？我以前不喜欢这个人，现在他们想当我的朋友。我该多大程度上信任他们？我应该相信他们吗？因此，男孩们在关于女孩真正如何看待事物这方面的教育确实存在很大的缺失。男孩们渴望这些知识，因为他们正在经历恋爱关系，并且他们想知道这些关系是如何运作的。你的新书《21世纪青少年男孩约会与性指南》再次为那些像你所说的那样，正在适应他们周围复杂的性世界的男孩们而写。
You know, as a therapist, what are some of the most common questions you get about dating and sex? And I'm also curious how parents can use this book as a way to talk with their sons about this. And I'm going to try to not get too complicated in this answer. With the boys I work with, and even with the adult men I work with, questions about, you know, how do I tell if someone's interested in me? Or my partner and I had an argument or things aren't going so well. And how do I fix it? And again, for boys, it tends to be about fixing things because we tend to raise boys to be problem solvers and not so much about how they feel about what's going to.
你知道，作为一名治疗师，你在约会和性方面遇到的最常见问题有哪些？我也很好奇父母如何利用这本书来与他们的儿子谈论这个话题。我尽量让这个回答不要太复杂。在我共事的男孩们，甚至是我共事的成年男性中，问题往往围绕着：我怎么知道别人对我有意思？或者我和伴侣吵架了，事情进展不太顺利，我该怎么解决？再次强调，对男孩来说，这往往关乎解决问题，因为我们将男孩培养成问题解决者，而不是让他们去关注自己对正在发生的事情有何感受，或者对伴侣有何感受。
on or how they feel about their partner. Something's going on. So as a therapist, they have a lot of conversation around those topics. And again, how do relationships work, how do feelings beat into those relationship dynamics? One of the ways that parents can use the book is to give them ideas for how to start conversations. The book is written for, you know, kind of average run-of-the-mill teen boys. So there's some acknowledgement of stereotypes, acknowledgement of the things that teen boys get pushed into like sports. And we know that somewhere north of 60% of team boys play sports, something like 80% follow at least one professional sport.
有事情正在发生。因此，作为一名治疗师，他们围绕这些话题进行了很多对话。再次强调，恋爱关系是如何运作的，情感是如何融入这些恋爱关系动态中的？父母使用这本书的方法之一就是为他们如何开启对话提供思路。这本书是为普通大众化的青春期男孩写的。因此，书中承认了一些刻板印象，承认了青春期男孩被迫参与的事情，比如体育运动。我们知道，有60%以上的青春期男孩参加体育运动，大约80%的人关注至少一项职业体育运动。
So a number of examples throughout the book of the kinds of things that boys tend to be interested in. You know, this is how a relationship might work in sports, but here's how it might be different if we're talking about a romantic partner. And parents can use that kind of framework in those examples as they're having conversations with their sons. In regard to what are the most common questions that boys have about dating and sex, I actually start the book with NFAQ, a frequently asked questions list. One of the biggest ones that boys ask of any sexuality educator is about penis size. The average is about six inches. there's much more detail in the book.
因此，书中自始至终都有许多例子，涉及男孩往往感兴趣的事物。你知道，这是恋爱关系在体育中可能运作的方式，但如果我们谈论的是浪漫伴侣，情况可能会有所不同。父母在与儿子交谈时，可以利用这种框架和这些例子。关于男孩们对约会和性最常见的问题是什么，我实际上在书的开头就列出了常见问题解答（FAQ）。男孩们问性教育工作者的最主要问题之一就是关于阴茎尺寸。平均长度约为六英寸，书中对此有更多详细的描述。
The FAQ questions get answered in two or three sentences right there in the beginning with additional references to sections later in the book that provide additional detail. I imagine the sex question is rather difficult for any parent, really. I know some mothers say, well, should I be having this conversation with my son? Should I leave it to my husband? Or what if I'm a single mom? And I don't have a husband around to help talk to my son about these issues. I'm not sure what your patients, your young patients say about that, but how do you address those types of difficult conversations?
FAQ中的问题在开头直接用两三句话得到了解答，并在后面提供了指向书中其他章节的引用，以提供更多细节。我想对于任何父母来说，性这个话题其实都挺难启齿的。我知道有些母亲会说，我是该和儿子谈论这个，还是留给我丈夫？或者如果我是个单亲妈妈，身边没有丈夫来帮我跟儿子谈论这些问题该怎么办？我不确定你的病人们，你的年轻病人们对此怎么看，但你是如何处理这些棘手的对话的？
I'm going to start with the parent piece of that. One of the things that the research tells us, and certainly I see this as a therapist, is that boys want information from someone that they can trust. For the vast majority of boys, the gender of that person doesn't really matter. There is a small segment of the teen boy population that really wants that to come from a, male. But for most boys, what is much more important than the biology of the person they're talking to is their trust in that person, whether or not they're going to get good information, whether or not that person is going to respect what the boy says as the conversation progresses. When it comes to what to talk about regarding sex, we as adults or as folks who work with
我从父母这一部分开始讲起。研究告诉我们的一点，而且作为一名治疗师我也确实看到了这一点，那就是男孩希望从他们信任的人那里获得信息。对于绝大多数男孩来说，这个人的性别其实并不重要。一小部分青春期男孩确实希望从男性那里获得这些信息。但对大多数男孩来说，比他们交谈对象的生物学性别更重要的是，他们对这个人的信任，即他们是否能获得好的信息，以及随着谈话的进行，这个人是否会尊重男孩所说的话。谈到关于性的讨论时，我们作为成年人或与青少年共事的人需要记住，
teams need to remember that there's a large range of behaviors that fall under this umbrella of sex or sexuality as I tend to refer to it. And we can start with where most of our boys start, which is with things like kissing and holding hands, and then work up to or, you know, down to, depending on how you want to think about it, more physically intimate kinds of sexual contact. But starting with, you know, what does it mean to hold somebody's hand? What does it mean to kiss somebody in public and kiss them like that in public? How do you know if you're ready to kiss somebody or if you want to kiss somebody?
在“性”或我倾向于称之为“性欲”这个大伞下，涵盖了广泛的行为。我们可以从大多数男孩开始的地方着手，比如接吻和牵手，然后逐步过渡到（或者根据你的理解，深入到）更具身体亲密感的性接触。但从以下问题开始，比如牵手意味着什么？在公共场合亲吻某人意味着什么，在公共场合那样亲吻他们意味着什么？你如何知道自己是否准备好亲吻某人，或者是否想要亲吻某人？
If we can start with those discussions when our boys are maybe in fifth or just often around of crushes and kind of dating, I remember having to apply to a group of girls to get a kissing license in fifth grade. That was how it worked in my class. You know, that's a point when we can start this conversation. and if we're starting by talking about how do you know when you're ready to hold hands, how do you know when you're ready to kiss, then a couple of years down the road, we're just changing the specific behavior.
如果我们能在男孩大约五年级，或者刚开始产生好感和约会时就开始这些讨论，我记得我在五年级时不得不向一群女孩申请接吻执照。我班上就是这样的。你知道，这就是我们可以开始这场对话的时机。如果我们从讨论“你如何知道自己什么时候准备好牵手”、“你如何知道自己什么时候准备好接吻”开始，那么几年之后，我们只是在改变具体的行为。
How do you know when you're ready for oral sex? How do you know when you're ready to be naked in front of somebody? How do you know when you're ready to have your penis inside somebody? So we can kind of scaffold this and make it a conversation that goes across years, but he's really focused on the behavior that seems most likely for the boy to engage in at the time. All right. So we've gone to the point now where my teenage son is either having sex or wants to have sex, you know, maybe as a girlfriend or a boyfriend, I'm concerned about sexually transmitted diseases
你如何知道自己什么时候准备好进行口交？你如何知道自己什么时候准备好在别人面前赤身裸体？你如何知道自己什么时候准备好让阴茎进入别人的身体？因此，我们可以建立这种阶梯式的教育，使其成为一项跨越多年的对话，但它真正关注的是男孩在当时最有可能参与的行为。好的。所以我们现在讨论到了这样的地步：我十几岁的儿子要么正在发生性行为，要么想要发生性行为，你知道，也许有了女朋友或男朋友，我开始担心性传播疾病
or an unwanted pregnancy. I'm guessing the best waiter approaches is not to just leave a couple of condoms next to his breakfast. You know, how do parents broach this? I mean, I really, I think that's the really big question, you know, how do you see? start the conversation. There is not conversation. I don't think leaving condoms on the table when there's cereal around is a good idea, especially if your son puts banana slices in there and you're not particularly awake in the morning.
或意外怀孕。我猜最好的应对方式不是直接把几个避孕套放在他的早餐旁边。你知道，父母该如何切入这个话题？我的意思是，真的，我认为这是一个非常大的问题，你知道，你如何看待？开启对话。我不认为在有麦片的时候把避孕套放在桌子上是个好主意，特别是如果你的儿子在里面放了香蕉片，而你早上又没怎么睡醒的话。
Like, that could just go all sorts of wrong. For conversations about protection, conversations about disease or unlawed pregnancies, there usually isn't a good way to start it. It's just going to be an awkward and difficult conversation. And what I often tell parents is you've got to do it. You know, it is not pleasant, but there's not really a good way to get there. Some parents who watch shows that their teens also watch might be able to find something on one of those shows where they get into that discussion. And so it's kind of an easy opening if you happen to be watching a show or a movie with your son and a couple.
这可能会以各种方式出错。对于关于保护的对话、关于疾病或意外怀孕的对话，通常没有一个很好的切入方式。这注定会是一场尴尬且艰难的对话。我经常告诉父母的是，你必须去做。你知道，这并不愉快，但并没有什么好方法能轻松切入。有些父母如果会看青少年也看的节目，可能会在其中一个节目中找到切入点，从而进入那个讨论。所以，如果你碰巧和儿子一起看一个节目或电影，而里面的一对情侣
is talking about an FTI or is talking about an unplanned pregnancy, that's a fine place, a fine starting point for the conversation. But I think when you're talking to your son about whether or not he's ready to have sex and some of the implications of having sex with somebody, that's a time when you also need to talk about protection because we want our sons to be thinking about protection before they have sex for the first time. Some of the research shows us that the kids who use condoms at their first sex are much more likely to continue using condoms regularly don't use condoms at the first sexual experience. Do you notice when you talk to kids about this if their parents do provide them with condoms, let's say, or tell them that they should get condoms and how to get them?
正在谈论性传播感染（STI）或意外怀孕，那将是一个很好的契机，是对话的良好起点。但我认为，当你和儿子谈论他是否准备好发生性行为以及与某人发生性行为的一些含义时，这也是你需要同时谈论保护措施的时候，因为我们希望我们的儿子在第一次发生性行为之前就考虑到保护措施。一些研究表明，在第一次性行为时使用避孕套的孩子，在随后的性生活中更有可能继续定期使用避孕套，而不使用避孕套的人则不会。你是否发现在与孩子们谈论这件事时，如果他们的父母确实给他们提供了避孕套，或者告诉他们应该去获得避孕套以及如何获得避孕套，情况会有所不同？
I think a lot of parents are concerned that they're giving their consent, as in, okay, go ahead. This is fine with mom and dad. And that's not necessarily the message everyone wants to send, right? I mean, to their young son. That's a gross majority of 16-year-olds are able to handle a kind of two-tiered answer or two-tiered value from their parents that says, I really don't want you to have sex until a certain age or a certain condition like you're really in love with the person. But I understand that you might choose otherwise. And if you do, I want you to be safe. I definitely want to talk about consent because this is a very timely and important issue. It's something you take a whole chapter to discuss in your book. No means no doesn't seem to be sufficient really in communicating what consent means.
我认为很多父母担心这等于给予了默许，就好像在说：“行吧，去吧。爸爸妈妈觉得这没问题。”这不一定是每个人都想传达的信息，对吧？我是说，对他们年轻的儿子来说。绝大多数16岁的孩子都能够理解来自父母的这种双层答案或双层价值观，即：“我真的不希望你在某个年龄或达成某些条件（比如你真的深爱着对方）之前发生性行为。但我理解你可能会做出不同的选择。如果你这样做了，我希望你是安全的。”我一定要谈谈“同意”这个词，因为这是一个非常及时且重要的问题。你在书里用了一整章来讨论它。“不就是不”似乎并不足以真正传达“同意”的含义。
How would you advise parents and their boys to discuss the issue of consent, not just getting consent, but from someone, but giving it as well. As we are talking to our boys about what are you willing to do and what are you not willing to do, what are you ready to do, whether we're talking about, are you ready to kiss, are you ready to hold hands, or are you ready to put your penis inside somebody? You know, their statement of I'm ready or I'm not ready reflect their level of consent and then point out and in many ways mandate that they get consent from their partner. You know, you wouldn't want somebody going inside your body without consent.
你将如何建议父母和他们的男孩讨论“同意”这一问题，不仅是如何获得别人的同意，还有如何给予同意。当我们与男孩讨论“你愿意做什么，不愿意做什么”、“你准备好做什么”时，无论我们谈论的是你准备好接吻了吗、你准备好牵手了吗，还是你准备好将你的阴茎放入别人的身体了吗，他们表态说“我准备好了”或“我没准备好”，这反映了他们的同意水平，同时也指出并在许多方面要求他们必须获得伴侣的同意。你知道，你不会希望别人未经同意就进入你的身体。
Why would you think it's okay to put your tongue or your penis in somebody else's body without their consent? And so it kind of becomes, or we can make it, part of the conversation about how do you know if you are ready and how do you know if your partner is ready? Sexual assault and rape are instances where consent did not happen or where somebody did not respect consent. And we know that for both boys and girls, there are a lot of negative psychological effects both in the immediate aftermath and downstream issues related to PTSD and depression and potentially self-harm in various ways, even suicide. We also know that there is a lot less public support and in some ways professional support for boys who have been sexually assaulted or raped.
为什么你会认为未经别人同意就把你的舌头或阴茎放进别人的身体里是可以的呢？所以这变成了一种，或者我们可以把它变成关于“你如何知道自己是否准备好了”以及“你如何知道你的伴侣是否准备好了”的对话的一部分。性侵犯和强奸是指没有发生同意或者有人不尊重同意的情况。我们知道，对于男孩和女孩来说，这都会带来许多负面的心理影响，包括直接的后果以及长期的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、抑郁症以及潜在的各种自残行为，甚至自杀。我们还知道，对于遭受性侵犯或强奸的男孩，公众的支持在很大程度上要少得多，在某些方面专业支持也较少。
and that among males who have been sexually assaulted and raped, the average time to disclose that event is somewhere around 20 years. So that's a long time to live with those effects. Yeah, yeah. I think there are a lot of things boys are dealing with now that didn't exist when their parents were teenagers. For example, pornography is more accessible thanks to the Internet. There are sites like Snapchat, Instagram,
在遭受性侵犯和强奸的男性中，平均公开披露这一事件的时间大约是20年。所以，带着这些影响生活是很长的一段时间。是的，是的。我认为男孩现在面对的许多事情是他们的父母做青少年时所不存在的。例如，多亏了互联网，色情内容变得更容易获得。还有Snapchat、Instagram等网站，
not to mention the prevalence of sexting. Is all of this changing how men, perceive sex and sexual relationships. How do we, and if so, how do we address that? There is for teens growing up today versus those of us who were teens, certainly in the 80s when I was, but even 15 years ago. We might also talk to our teams about, I am going to look at your phone or periodically I see your phone because you leave it face up when we're sitting at dinner or whatever,
更不用说色情短信（sexting）的盛行了。所有这一切是否正在改变男性对性以及性关系的看法？我们该如何应对，如果是的话，我们该如何应对？对于当今长大的青少年来说，与我们这些青少年时期相比——当然是在80年代我当青少年的时期，甚至是在15年前——情况确实有所不同。我们也可以跟青少年谈谈，比如：“我会看你的手机，或者我偶尔会看你的手机，因为我们坐在餐桌旁时你总是把它正面朝上放着，无论如何，”
and this is what I want to see or not see on your, on the front. screen of your phone because most teens set their phone so that their text come up right on front. And we definitely need to talk to our teens, both boys and girls, about the pressure that they're experiencing to send naked pictures or half-naked pictures of themselves, the pressure they may be experiencing to share pictures that they've received with other kids because we know that that happens and help them weave through kind of what are some of the issues. What are the benefits that I gain from sending a picture like this, from getting a picture like this? What are the drawbacks or the potential drawbacks?
这就是我想在你的手机屏幕上看到或不想看到的东西，因为大多数青少年设置手机时都会让短信直接显示在主屏幕上。我们绝对需要和我们的青少年（无论是男孩还是女孩）谈谈他们感受到的压力，即发送自己裸照或半裸照的压力，以及他们可能感受到的压力，即与其他人分享他们收到的照片，因为我们知道这种情况会发生，并帮助他们厘清其中的一些问题。我从发送这样的照片、从收到这样的照片中能获得什么好处？有哪些缺点或潜在的缺点？
Because they often don't have good frameworks for thinking about the different pieces of that in part because they've never been asked or told to think about those different pieces and all in one conversation. And then there's porn. We know that for adults and good to remind our teens that this is really about adults. fantasy and kind of you're not there yet, should remind them about what's missing from those videos. We might talk about what body types are present and not present. If you look at the guys in most of those porn videos, they're all incredibly well-built. We might also ask about, you know, what do the women's bodies look like? Because it tends to be that standard Hollywood model body there. We can ask them, where's consent? Where's the relationship?
因为他们通常没有良好的框架来思考其中的不同部分，部分原因在于他们从未被要求或被告知要在一次对话中把这些不同的部分全部思考清楚。然后是色情片。我们知道这适合成年人，并且很好地提醒我们的青少年，这实际上是成年人的幻想，而你还没到那个阶段，应该提醒他们这些视频中缺少了什么。我们可以讨论存在和不存在哪些体型。如果你看看大多数色情片里的男人，他们都练得极其健美。我们还可以问，你知道，女性的身体长什么样？因为那往往是标准的好莱坞模特身材。我们可以问他们，同意在哪里？关系在哪里？
in here. This is not reality. Well, Dr. Smiler, thank you so much for joining us. It's been very interesting conversation. Thank you. It's been a pleasure to be here. Thanks for listening. If you would like to purchase a copy of Dr. Smiler's book, or if you want to just hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在这里。这不是现实。好的，斯迈勒博士，非常感谢你加入我们。这是一场非常有趣的对话。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。感谢收听。如果你想购买斯迈勒博士的书的副本，或者如果你想听更多的剧集，请访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会“心理学访谈”节目的奥德丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。